this is Jana suka here I who's the the
arrow is over and I was in Fukushima on
the sixth anniversary of the nuclear
disaster there and I learned about here
I when I was there because he was the
engineer who was behind the own Ogawa
nuclear power station which was closer
to the epicenter of the earthquake the
Tohoku earthquake of 2011 that destroyed
the Fukushima nuclear power plant led to
the meltdown and owned Ogawa even though
it was closer to the epicenter had been
safe it was a place of refuge for people
in the city during the disaster and I
wanted to understand so why was owned
Ogawa safe when Fukushima you know was
not and and it was really this engineers
named who came up several times because
he had insisted that that nuclear power
station to be built further back from
the sea with a higher elevation and with
a higher seawall and the reason that he
insisted on that he didn't live to see
this earthquake by the way but the
reason he insisted on it was because he
had this memory he had this knowledge I
should say of his hometown shrine which
had had a plaque honoring the sort of
memory of a tsunami from the year 869
the Shogun earthquake and he carried
that knowledge that a tsunami could have
that kind of destructive effect and it
led to how he thought about this and
planned for this piece of infrastructure
this nuclear power plant in a way that
was had more greater foresight than than
the TEPCO the the nuclear power company
that ran Fukushima and so I think part
of the lesson here is that we need
longer historical memory so often we're
only thinking back and that's was just
thinking it's also the models we use to
predict future risks so TEPCO the Tokyo
Electric Power Company which was behind
the Fukushima owned Fukushima Daiichi
that nuclear power station they were
using computer models to model risks
like tsunami like an earthquake to their
power station but they were their data
only went back something like a couple
of decades and the one and a thousand
year event of an earthquake like the one
that happened in 2011
have been put into their models but they
didn't look far enough back